there are ducks who love snails who love  wine yes these tiny mollusks are as  crazy about wine as we humans they wreak  havoc in South Africa's fashion oak de  state which lies in one of the country's  main wine producing regions this  vineyard alone produces over 300  thousand bottles of red wine per year  these invasive white dune snails devour  the leaves and stems of the vines that  is until this colorful duck parade  marches in to save the day  every morning like clockwork more than a  thousand of these agile Indian runner  ducks are released from their pens they  head straight into the vineyards to  feast themselves silly on the little  critters the quacking snail squad can  cover a total of 100 square metres per  day the advantage of the Ducks is that  unlike chemicals the birds don't harm  bees or any of the other useful insects  this ecological approach earned the  vineyard a wff biodiversity certificate  so let's give a big quack quack to that